llamas de varios metros de altura
incontrolables amenazando viviendas en
estos pueblos de Asturias en el norte de
España los habitantes son evacuados en
plena noche y Bueno estamos súper
tristes acongojados con las ganas de
llorar en todo momento más de 600
bomberos están desplegados Desde el
miércoles para luchar contra los
numerosos incendios que se han declarado
muchos de ellos procedentes de regiones
vecinas pero con la sequía que afecta a
todo el país las llamas ganan terreno No
sé no se puede producir nada la
meteorología puede cambiar pero bueno si
no llueve obviamente es muy complicado
si ya se está comprobando va cada vez
más aire
los incendios hay mucha vegetación
no es cuestión de tampoco haber acaba de
nos comentan que cruzó la autopista
incendios simultáneos que las
autoridades creen que son de origen
criminal
Me están quemando no porque es muy
intencionado y hay que decirlo
abiertamente una hipótesis compartida
por los habitantes de la región que se
encuentran conmocionados Entonces
claramente que son fuegos intencionados
Entonces no sé con qué fin no lo sabemos
pero lo que sí sabemos que es la ruina
total el país también se enfrenta el
primer gran incendio de la temporada en
la comunidad valenciana los bomberos han
conseguido estabilizarlo pero ya se han
esfumado casi 5000 hectáreas de terreno